[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  me  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]